hey how's it going bros my name is Barry
[Music]
welcome to yandere simulator there's
some more part of this game than we do
in a really fully check out Sevareid
coming so we're just gonna do just that
alright I ride I ride alright we're
gonna start this off by selecting our
panties great way to start a video I'm
feeling very strawberry today alright
alright alright alright alright some
strawberry hedges it is fantastic now
let's say our prayers to Lord sempai
Oh Sam pie please one day will you
please notice me by the power of this
apple bandage and toothbrush thank you
I ride I ride I ride let's go to school
fantastic ah so another day at the
yandere simulator high school I better
sneak so senpai doesn't see me no one
would ever see me when I walk like this
I'm practically invisible
[Music]
whoa what's that what is this this
senpai mode I think this is set I can
see through walls and [ __ ] so our goal
for this episode is to take a bunch of
panty shots because apparently if you
have penny shots you can sell the panty
shots for like blackmailing delay the
cops very useful stuff just just maybe
guys have panties - that'd be working
[ __ ] something I mean I don't want
female clothes
that's this [ __ ] weird alright oh my
god it's this [ __ ] oh my god it's Becky
I [ __ ] hate her [ __ ] get rag yeah
don't worry she says she's a salvage she
can breathe it underneath water calm
down my friends she's not dead she's
just alright perfect time perfect time
to take panty shots one panty shot oh
it's just dead panty shot doesn't count
if they're dead what that [ __ ] is this
game okay alright alright the teachers
coming [ __ ]
let's drag the corpse hurry up hurry up
is Louise your [ __ ] cleavage is
showing Jesus Christ guess you're not a
cell by now are ya pathetic little
Salman [ __ ] show you who's boss no no
no no no no here we are
Charlotte no no it wasn't me I swear to
god I'm innocent [ __ ] I became a tree
hate when that happens
let's try that let's try that again that
was not the it's not the best gonna fire
my step I'm gonna hold and tak gonna
grab the symphony I gotta sit by don't
worry guys I'm just giving a nice
friendly shampooing her hair was greasy
as [ __ ] ere we go she's not dead she's
just dreaming okay it looks like wagster
they got away with it yeah bench let's
dump the body actually let's take a
picture first the pictures are worth
money ascends it good good work but
don't send me this stuff I have no use
of it dad
no no she's not dead she's not dead
hurry hurry hurry hadn't better she
carried her hoodie everyone for you come
on come on get in there oh god they're
coming get in the furnace this
conveniently placed furnace get it up
I'm in and said see nothing you see
nothing
yeah that's right [ __ ] well yeah what's
the problem just enjoying just enjoying
my time here a junior I was this just a
point yeah was that just a prank think
it's very funny yes not very funny my
time like yet to waste her time like
that I'm coming for you next [ __ ] oh my
God look at his face
why do you want to say you look lovely
really why thank you that's so nice of
you to say anything for you my new
friend
oh god it's a fight [ __ ] me God adds
this gave me some [ __ ] weird
oh man the cops are gonna come in one
minute really wait like are the cops
gonna come but I need to take panty
shots
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that bode Oh God
what happened the police arrived without
any evidence that the unburied Chan had
committed the murder their police could
not take action
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
getting the way with murder that's what
you get for looking at senpai okay
the center moment panty shot moment come
on come on
I almost got a penny god damn it's so
hard to get a panty shot people don't
appreciate a good panty shot you see or
the [ __ ] is Salman girl going computer
room ha interesting very interesting it
is you can't see me can she
what's she doing by the computer what
the [ __ ] is in her way
now how do I kill a [ __ ] okay
apparently and one minute the purple
hair [ __ ] diet there she goes for her
month her weekly [ __ ] is coming we're
gonna follow her though no one would
suspect a thing
all girls poop together everyone knows
this rat she doesn't see us following
her biggest mistake of her life the last
mistake of her life she actually goes
inside she closed the door damn it oh
she's she's she damn it let me end I was
supposed to drop ya goddamnit [ __ ] [ __ ]
you she's taunting me she's taunting me
with her dance
god dammit how do i reset there's a
small window to drown this [ __ ] that we
have to take all right let me open the
door for ya enjoy hey giant pump
that's just too bad how dare you breathe
the same air as senpai hello fellow
students this [ __ ] [ __ ] with me
and I want you all to know that if
anyone else [ __ ] with me you can expect
the same treatment the [ __ ] is coming
over
ain't nobody [ __ ] with egg I roll this
down Jesus Christ
[ __ ] hell oh my god oh my God look at
her that's awesome do anything
senpai everybody get away from me but I
did it for you
[Music]
I press if you bros enjoy this video
leave a like subscribe to come for it
today and i'll see you in the next one
it's always stay awesome brush
[Music]